- Pump the music, I know how to do this.
I got spat on in school.
I was big, I was black, I was gay.
The day that happened,
I had to breakthrough,
and my breakthrough was once I stood up,
everyone else seemed like, "Oh, shit."
♪ I like to, like to get down ♪
I'm Precious, and I'm
part of the legendary
Ballroom Scene of New York City.
♪ Let's get some clappin'
and get this energy high ♪
So, Ballroom's like a huge safe haven
for people of LGBTQI experience.
♪ Like this, don't you stop ♪
♪ Make that cookie pop ♪
When I seen that the commentators
were like the center
of attention at a Ball,
I was like, "Oh, this needs to be my job."
♪ Walk, eat, slay ♪
♪ Miss Lolita ♪
Growing up in the Ballroom,
you'd be surprised
at how many people are
gonna appreciate you
for being who you are.
And gender non-binary for me,
I don't feel like I have to be like a boy,
or I don't feel like I have to be a girl.
Just think of water,
has no limits, it moves.
Ooh, this orange is
sending me, Miss Honey.
What can make you feel
better about yourself?
For me, that was putting on makeup.
It gives me that touch of femininity.
It gives me like the
deepness of masculinity.
Like, my eyebrows speaks for itself.
It's just oh yeah, big bitch energy.
It's me.
♪ Do you wanna take a bite ♪
♪ Of this cookie ♪
I want to be known for
someone who uplifted people
across the world.
And for me that was getting on the mic.
'Cause I can get on the mic
and I can give you something you can feel.
And Ballroom helped me
with that, trust me.
♪ All my people had to fight ♪
♪ But without a fight ♪
♪ There wouldn't have been no success ♪
♪ Hi, my name is Precious ♪
♪ Let me get this off my chest ♪
(logo dings)